es la fiesta de la vacuna en israel una
celebración para festejar la aplicación
de la segunda dosis del fármaco que
protege contra el commit 19 son imágenes
de un hogar para la tercera edad que fue
tomado por la euforia olvidando los
protocolos de bioseguridad y aún bajo la
incertidumbre de saber si los vacunados
siguen transmitiendo o no el virus ellos
hacen parte de cerca del 30 por ciento
de la población que ya ha recibido al
menos una dosis en israel un país con
unos 9 millones de habitantes la
situación de israel está por encima de
otros territorios en donde el panorama
varía desde el cerca de 20% de vacunados
en emiratos árabes unidos- y el 0 65% de
francia la línea que se empieza a marcar
preocupa a un panel de expertos de la
organización mundial de la salud que
ilustra con este mapa el panorama de
áfrica en donde estiman no habrá una
vacunación de amplio acceso hasta 2022 o
incluso 2023 countries más los países se
deben comprometer con un acceso
inclusivo de la vacuna esto es un
imperativo moral y de salud pública en
américa la vacuna también divide al
norte y al sur de eeuu avanza ya con un
porcentaje
37 por ciento de vacunados y canadá con
un 15 por ciento la unión americana ha
aplicado cerca de un 90 por ciento de
las inyecciones de todo el continente
mientras tanto en américa latina sólo 5
países han comenzado las inoculaciones y
ninguno llega al 1% los países con más
recursos iniciaron en negociaciones
directas con las farmacéuticas y
cortaron la mayor cantidad de dosis en
el mercado que hay actualmente esto pone
en desventaja a los países pobres que no
han tenido el mismo acceso a las vacunas
y que muchos países ni siquiera han
iniciado vacunas esta situación no deja
una buena imagen sobre el mecanismo
kóvacs respaldado por la organización
mundial de la salud con el que se busca
una repartición equitativa de la vacuna
sin embargo según este panel
independiente lado ms necesita una
reforma para abordar la crisis sanitaria
global una situación que de acuerdo con
esos expertos los está sobrepasando